chris thank you very much here's
breaking news we're following again this
shooting in southern california
yesterday the suspect in this mass
shooting at a presbyterian church a man
from here in las vegas here's the latest
from the orange county sheriff and so
we're going to give you today as much
information as we possibly can to
connect the dots
and tell you a story that tragedy that
occurred
yesterday
afternoon in orange county
first i want to start with the
individual involved in this this is an
isolated incident
we do know that the individual at least
every information that we have to this
day
shows that this individual was acting
alone
and we do know that based on information
we've collected and i'm not going to go
into the details of that evidence
was a politically motivated
hate incident
a grievance that this individual had
between himself
and the taiwanese community
at large
all right so there is a live again press
conference happening on this shooting in
orange county we have it live on eight
news now dot com the suspect from here
in las vegas and we're having more
details on this story later on today